just before he jump into the video today
I do want to say that this guy is a
German his name is John hob and I hope
I'm pronouncing that right Germans but I
do want to say for all of the viewers
today I'm probably gonna screw that up
at some point I'm probably just gonna go
with calling him John rabe because it's
easier for me to pronounce rather than
trying with the whole tracker thing for
the whole video so that's that out of
the way let's get into it what would you
think of a man who supported the
greatest mass murder machine in human
history a man who was proud to stand by
a genocidal dictator who nearly
destroyed Europe a man proud to call
himself a Nazi would you find him
sickening or evil well maybe not if he
was John rabe a high-ranking Nazi Rob
was an ardent supporter of a Dolf Hitler
but he was also something else he was
perhaps the greatest humanitarian that
you've never heard of known as the good
Nazi of Nanking rabb was the Third
Reich's man in China when the capital
fell to Japan's German aligned forces
faced with the Imperial Army's genocide
all actions he did something wholly
unexpected he tried to save the lives of
every Chinese civilian in the city over
six incredible weeks John rabe stood at
the epicenter of a bloodbath
single-handedly protecting nan Kings
residence from a whirlwind of rape and
murder he is today credited with saving
250,000 lives and deeded all of this
while still staying loyal to Adolphe
Hitler today we delve into the
fascinating story of history's could not
see
[Music]
when John rap was born in Hamburg on
November the 23rd 1882 it was into a
world that was on the cusp of a dramatic
change just a year before the rising
state of Germany had delivered a
surprise knockout blow to France in the
franco-prussian war for ABS
contemporaries that meant growing up at
a time of unbridled optimism not that
Rob thought much of it taken out of
school at a young age when his ship
captain father suddenly died and stuck
into an unhappy apprenticeship young
John was a boy always hoping to escape
Germany and see the world and so he did
in 1903 the 21 year old Rob set out for
the Portuguese African colony of lurin
qua mark now Maputo in Mozambique it
seems he planned to stay there long term
but an outbreak of malaria forced him to
return to Hamburg after just three years
for John this was a blessing in disguise
back in Hamburg he met up with an old
school crush named Dora and was
delighted to discover that she was into
him too
the two courted they fell in love and
became the sickening German version of
those love dead couples who can't spend
a single second apart if John had been a
slightly more average man well that
would have been it but John he wasn't
average despite looking like a man
cursed by a witch - forever resemble a
Certified Accountants John Robb had an
adventurous soul three years in Africa
it simply hasn't been enough him so in
1908 he presented Dora with a plan the
two of them would move to Shanghai
rather than ask if her new lover gone
mad Dora replied with the early 20th
century Germanic equivalents of how yes
neither of them could have known they'd
chosen to move to a kingdom on the verge
of catastrophe on November the 15th 1908
the Dowager Empress 6e breathed her last
in the imperial gardens of Beijing the
power behind the throne in China since
1865 her passing left the Ching dynasty
dangerously unstable already left
reeling by the recent Boxer Rebellion
the family that had ruled China for over
250 years at now lost its matriarch 6e
was replaced on the throne by her
two-year-old Puyi and spoiler alert here
don't bother memorizing that name
as the aftershocks of 60s death rumbled
through Chinese society John and Dora
they were entering a new era of their
own in 1909 the young couple married in
1910 Jean got a position as a clerk in a
Siemens office in Beijing it was a
position that would allow him to rise up
quickly through the ranks becoming a
pillar of the German expat community it
was also a position that would give him
a front-row seat as China exploded
[Music]
there's an old Chinese curse that goes
may you live in interesting times well
times in China they were certainly about
to get interesting on October the 10th
1911 the city of Wu Chang exploded in
rebellion against the Emperor boy this
lit the fuse on roughly a bazillion
other powder kegs and in no time at all
half of China was in revolt known as the
Xing hai revolution it ended when
six-year-old Bowie abdicated in January
of 1912 ending the Ching dynasty for a
revolution that closed the door on 2,000
years of imperial rule the Tsing I
revolution it went remarkably smoothly
China was declared a republic and Yuan
Shikai became its head like most other
German expats John and Dora rabe were
almost totally unaffected by the sudden
change river of power however the same
could not be said for the next problem
that was going to afflict China and that
of course was world war 1 okay at this
point we probably needs a backtrack a
little for a quick historical explainer
for about three hundred years before
their abs had arrived China had been the
most powerful nation in the East then in
1853 a guy called Commodore Perry led a
fleet of ships into Edo Bay just outside
of Tokyo and threatened to blast the
city into rubble unless Japan opened up
its economy the result was the opening
of Japan under the Meiji government good
news for American trade very bad news
for China this new Japan it quickly
became a regional powerhouse as China
lumbered along in ossified Twilight
Japan started throwing its weight around
like a sumo wrestler receiving
electroshock therapy in 1895 Japan even
whooped Beijing in the first
sino-japanese war this was an epic
humiliation for China and it got even
more epic when Germany took advantage of
China's weakness to occupy Qingdao in
1897 setting up the German Shandong when
World War one finally rolled around
China was eager to reclaim the stolen
territory unfortunately Tokyo they
weren't done humiliating them just yet
in late 1914 Japan and Britain joined
forces to invade Shandong kicking the
Germans out one of Tokyo's conditions
for joining the fight was that China
wouldn't be allowed to get involved the
Allies agreed with China castrated as
effectively as a eunuch Japan gobbled up
more territory taking South Manchuria in
the Wars aftermath the Allies pressed
China to officially cede Shandong and
South Manchuria to Japan Japan was
further endowed and China was further
humiliated perhaps in response 1919 saw
China kick out its German expats
including John and Dora rabe despite
having lived in China for more than a
decade suddenly they were personas
non-grata the death of President Yuan
Shikai back in 1916 had by 1919
triggered a collapse of Chinese society
known as the warlord era with China
Balcon izing into competing states
constantly at war with one another the
cities desperately needed foreign
expertise to stop themselves from
imploding
before 1919 was even out john and/or
arab had been begrudging li invited back
in
the warlord era came to a close in 1928
when nationalist troops led by Chiang
kai-shek succeeded in reunifying China
by force they established a new capital
in Nanking beginning something called
the Nanking decade it was a time of
prosperity that China had not seen since
before World War one the economy it
boomed stability rains and people's
lives improved among them was John rabe
throughout the warlord era this quiet
German businessman had plugged away with
typical Central European efficiency
rising through the ranks of Siemens
Asian division even as China crumbled
all around him in the boom times of the
Nanking decade Siemens made Rob Managing
Director of its Chinese division
delighted John and Dora they moved to
Nanking in 1931 but 1931 was also the
year that the wheels started to come off
the new era on September the 18th
Japanese forces used the pretext of a
terrorist attack in South Manchuria to
invade Manchuria proper setting up a pro
Japanese puppet state under our old
friends Emperor Puyi rather than fight
this new aggression the Chinese did
something that probably seemed smart at
the time but in retrospect does look a
bit stupid they took their case to the
League of Nations set up in the wake of
World War 1 the League of Nations was
meant to settle disputes between nations
without the need for war in practice
though it was pretty weak and toothless
when it concluded the Japanese had been
wrong to invade Manchuria the Tokyo
delegation stormed off rather than cool
tensions the league have actually raised
them the things they wouldn't explode
just yet back in Nanking John rabe was
becoming the most important Westerner in
all of China in 1934 he opens a German
School on his property and made himself
the chairman this brought him into
contact for the first time with the Nazi
Party that same year Adolphe Hitler had
become Germany's unchallenged dictator
and yes the emphasis on the first
syllable there was fully intentional in
this dark new world being a public
german figure meant being a Nazi even if
he lived in China but this wasn't a
problem for Rob he already loved Nazism
historians struggle to her
Salva humanitarian John rabe with the
fascist John rabe although he joined the
party late in 1934 Robb quickly became
one of Hitler's biggest cheerleaders he
wrote of the regime I believe not only
in the correctness of our political
system but as an organizer of the party
I am behind the system 100% remember
this is a man who had many Chinese
friends who considered China his home
and Harry was throwing his support
behind a system that considered the
Chinese inferior the best guess
historians have is that rave as an expat
5,000 miles away from home was unaware
of National Socialism racism at the same
time he was enthused by the socialism
part with its emphasis on protecting the
dignity of the working man whatever the
truth Rob soon rose up the ranks of the
party and became the leading Nazi and
Nanking it was a rise that would
coincide with one of the worst
atrocities in modern history
[Music]
on July the 7th 1937 a skirmish broke
out on the market Polo Bridge between
Chinese and Japanese forces it was just
one of many such clashes that happened
following the occupation of men Korea
but this time something went wrong the
clash progressed into a battle and the
battle progressed into a Japanese
invasion and the invasion while that
progressed into a war that's right the
second sino-japanese war it had just
begun and it would make the first one
look like a bit of a stroll in the park
right from the off the Imperial Army
steamrolled across China in no time at
all they were converging upon Nanjing as
bombers rained fiery death down on the
city all of those with money they fled
among them were John and Dora Rob who
joined a tide of Westerners streaming
away for the relative safety of places
like peat hi-ho but John and Dora
they weren't never ones to lay low and
avoid danger on September the 21st they
returned to Nanking as John would later
write in his diary he didn't just return
to protect his property but because he
felt he had a duty to his Chinese
employees and here's where we get to the
really difficult part Rob didn't return
to help Nanking in spite of being a Nazi
he did it because he was a Nazi as hard
as it might be for us to stomach it was
the ideology of Nazism that made Rob
feel that he had to stay protecting his
Chinese workers as the Fuhrer was
protecting Germany's working men by
October barely 20 Westerners remained in
the city as the Imperial Army closed in
Rob called the other expats to his house
and 14 responded among them American
doctor Robert O Wilson we have to do
something Rob told them that something
was the nanking safety zone Rob's plan
was simple
despite being completely unarmed the 14
Westerners would unilaterally establish
a two and a half square mile zone of
neutrality in Nanking centered on Rob's
house and the German school surrounded
by white flags it would protect as many
Chinese civilians as necessary when word
got to the advancing Imperial Army it
dispatched a major arc a to try and talk
this crazy German out of staying as Rob
later recalled arca came to
in person and asked why in the devil did
you stay why do you want to involve
yourself in our military affairs what
does all of this matter to you you
haven't lost anything here looking the
major in the eye
John Raab replied I've been living here
in China for over thirty years my kids
and grandchildren were born here and I'm
happy and successful here if I had spent
thirty years in Japan Nan's were treated
just as well by the Japanese people you
can be assured that in a time of
emergency such as the situation China
faces now I would not leave the side of
the people in Japan the loyalty and rub
statement it seemed to touch something
in the majors soul Baca agreed Rob could
stay in the zone and that no harm would
come to him unfortunately he said
nothing about what would happen to any
Chinese man that Rob tried to shelter
his fall gave way to a bitter winter Rob
Wilson and others plastered Nanking in
posters telling citizens about the zone
Rob even personally sent a telegram to
Hitler asking him to request the
Japanese acknowledge the zones
neutrality you can probably guess how
that one went during the last few days
before Nanking fell Rob dramatically
draped buildings in the zone with vast
Nazi flags hoping to deter Javanese
bombers he had swastikas painted on
walls decked his car out in party
regalia and took to wearing his Nazi
uniform in public at the last moment
rankings mayor officially handed power
over to rob and fled the city now all
robbing the rest of his expats could do
was wait on December the 11th heavy
shelling had started as the bombardment
increased the last Chinese in the
capital flooded into the zone a quarter
of a million people converged on Rob's
property sleeping in ditches cramming
themselves into tents climbing across
one another just to be let in it was a
wave of human desperation unlike
anything the Westerners had ever seen
two nights later Rob stood at a window
with Dora watching the columns of flames
to the south in his garden below a
crawling mass of humanity wailed and
screamed and begged for their lives as
the screaming and the shelling grew
louder Rob finally snapped donning a
metal helmet he strode into the garden
and screamed at the refugees to shut up
he said that it was all going to be fine
the Japanese would
unfairly he was absolutely sure of it
but his words they were lost in the din
of the gunfire if they had carried it's
unlikely anyone would have heeded them
it was December the 13th 1937 and
apocalypse it was in the air as the
flames roared har the refugees huddled
tight together whatever happens next
they knew that it would not be fine on
the morning of December the 14th John
rabe awoke to a city blanketed in eerie
calm donning his uniform he ventured out
into the cold empty streets beyond the
zone wondering what he would find out
there the roads of Nanking were littered
with corpses hundreds of civilians lay
lifeless in the streets shot in the back
as they fled bodies of women had been
mutilated their vaginas penetrators by
bayonet blades on a street corner robbed
found a small contingent of Japanese
troops looting a German cafe when he
tried to stop them they laughed although
they didn't harm rob they burned the
cafe down amused by his impotence as he
returns from this unsettling expedition
Rob passed a bedraggled bunch of 400
Chinese Army regulars trying to retreat
they were exhausted
stumbling cut off from safety the sight
of them was so pitiful that Rob to hold
the soldiers that they could take refuge
in the zone on the one condition that
they disarmed he still felt certain the
Imperial Army would respect the zones
neutrality that tonight diplomat katsu
Okazaki called on Rob who was still
acting as the mayor of the city he
informed the German that they'd received
intelligence that soldiers were in the
zone he told Rob that have to be
arrested but he assured him that no harm
would come to them unable to do anything
else
Rob agreed over the next few days
Japanese fighters marched through the
zone looking for Chinese soldiers their
method for detection was to look for
calluses on their hands from firing
rifles to Rob's horror thousands of
young men were dragged from the zone the
vast majority of them rickshaw drivers
and workers who'd been wrongly
identified they were lined up just
outside and machine guns their bodies
being dumped into ponds it was John
Rob's first encounter with the brutality
of the Imperial Army and it would not be
his last as the tense December day
past rumors began to drift into the zone
of atrocities being committed outside of
it there were reports of Japanese
soldiers going from house to house
looking for women to rape aged it was
not an issue there were reports of
abused girls who were so young that the
soldiers slit open their genitals so
they could fit inside them boys were
forced at gunpoint to rape their own
mothers men raped their own daughters
women who'd been abused were sexually
tortured to death their genitals
mutilated in the zone John rabe listened
to these reports with a mounting horror
again and again he petitioned the
Japanese officers who did nothing he
telegrams Germany and demanded help but
nothing came just before Christmas of
1937 something in him it seems to have
snapped cut off from the rest of the
world in the city that had gone mad
Rob came to an inescapable conclusion if
he wanted these atrocities to stop he
would have to do something to stop them
himself and this begins the inspiring
chapter of John Rob's life the moment
when he did something so mad so
courageous he can only be called a hero
with Nanking burning around him Rob
dressed in his Nazi regalia left the
relative safety of the zone completely
unarmed he set out to save the city's
residence this was nothing short of
insanity Rob might have been protected
by the Imperial Army's officers but it
was a very noose protection out on the
streets he was just a man and a man
without a gun who was staring down the
bayonets of Japanese soldiers and yet
that is what he did
day after day as the Sun crawled up into
the winter sky Rob would leave the zone
listening to cries of help for the
tell-tale screams he would follow these
shrieks until he found the marauding
soldiers stormed right up to them shove
his swastika armband in their faces and
give them a brutal dressing-down
amazingly it worked terrified by this
German barking orders at them the
soldiers they fled Rob would then take
the girl they'd been abusing Walker to
his car and instruct the driver to take
her to the zone then it simply carry on
walking looking for the next woman in
trouble and then the next and the next
now it's really impossible to overstate
just how crazy this was Rob could have
been killed
of times yet there was something about
his authority something about the way he
wielded his Nazi Party membership that
put the fear of God into the Imperial
Army elsewhere the Nazi swastika became
a symbol of hate in Rob's hands it
became a symbol of hope yet Rob was not
just some silent angel passing through
the hell of Nanking he was a man capable
of understanding the need for warmth for
Humanity he and Dora organized the
birthday parties for children in the
zone singing songs as death and demons
clawed at the doors unsurprisingly most
of the boys born in the zone that winter
they were named John Rob also managed to
win over his fellow Westerners dr.
Wilson was a staunch anti-nazi who
considered anyone who joined the party
evil yet even he grew to respect this
one Nazi even if he could never
understand how Rob could be so good
while supporting something that was so
evil six weeks after the zones first
refugees arrived the end it finally came
in the dying literally cold days of
January the Imperial Army's High Command
reasserted control over their forces in
Nanking they marched into the zone and
removed the refugees a collaborator
government was set up and the rapes were
stopped in a cruel irony the Imperial
Army triumphantly proclaimed that that
restored order to the city today it's
estimated that a minimum of 20,000 women
were raped during the fall of Nanking
the widely accepted death toll arranges
from a hundred thousand to three hundred
thousand prisoners of war were
decapitated with swords they were blown
up with land mines they were doused in
petrol and set on fire in Japan many
still deny that The Rape of Nanking ever
happened less than a month after the
zone was dismantled Roth got a call from
Siemens ordering him home to Germany
packing as many films and photos of the
massacre as he could he promised Wilson
it spread word of The Rape of Nanking
back in Europe then he boarded a plane
with Dora and he left
now is it for John Rob as soon as he
touched down in Germany he was arrested
by the Gestapo for annoying their
Japanese allies he was imprisoned and it
was only the intervention of Siemens CEO
that saved him reassigned to a lonely
clerical position Rob spent the next few
years struggling just to make ends meet
when World War two ended in mid 1945 his
former standing within the Nazi Party
saw him arrested again this time by the
Allies but on trial Rob was only saved
this time around by testimony from dr.
Wilson left to rot in jail for a year
Rob was finally declared dinars off ID
in 1946 and he was released with a stain
of Nazi membership clinging to his soul
the last years of John Rob's life saw
him become unemployable as the post-war
German economic miracle saw living
standards rise in the defeated nation
John and Dora Robb sank into helpless
poverty the only thing that kept them
going in those harsh years were
semi-regular food parcels covered in
Chinese writing their return address it
was always Nanking finally in January of
1952 on Rob keeled over and died of a
stroke it was 68 by the time he died rob
was a nobody a source of shame back home
in Germany had been written out of the
Chinese history of Nanking by the newly
installed Communist Party those who've
been in Nanking they remembered him but
the rest of the world they forgot
in the 1990s iris Chang was researching
the Nanjing Massacre she uncovered Rob's
Diaries alongside stacks of documents
relating to his involvement in the
safety zone piecing his incredible story
together she managed to return his name
to the world at large not long after the
Chinese government paid to have routs
gravestone taken from Berlin and
reinterred in Nanjing the modern city
that john and dora had known as Nanking
it was placed at the site of a gigantic
memorial to the massacre after half a
century Rob had finally been returned to
the country which had fought for and had
loved so much nowadays it is estimated
that Rob's actions in banking saved
somewhere in the region of 250,000 lives
nearly everyone who made it into the
zone
by contrast the far more famous oskar
schindler saved 1200 people there is no
doubt that Schindler was a hero but Rob
he was something more he was a savior as
history's good Nazi once wrote if you
can do some good why hesitate so I
really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did please do give us a thumbs up
below and don't forget to subscribe
we've got brand new videos just like
this several times a week so hit that
subscribe button and you'll find out all
about those and if you're looking for
something else to watch why not click on
one of the videos on the screen now and
as always thank you for watching